[Music]
surrounded by the stunning vineyards of
the sierra nevada foothills is murphy's
california a picturesque destination for
wine enthusiasts and tourists this
historic town has been home to murphy's
hotel for over 150 years
the hotel has an illustrious history
presidents and legends have come to stay
in this national landmark
partners brian kevin and joel bought the
business nine months ago
i own the hotel with my two partners i
run the dining room i'm the dinner
manager kevin he's our bar manager and
joel he's our chef wonderful thank you
but it's no one's job to look after the
hotel
it's historic but i think it needs to be
maintenance
the historic rooms i wouldn't even stay
in them and i get a discount that's air
conditioning that's it
behind the historic main building there
are 20 so-called modern bedrooms
the modern rooms are maybe modern in the
60s these are modern this kind of looks
like my grandma's house
like it too
[Music]
sadly the owners are too busy drinking
in the bar to notice the state of the
hotel oh man owning a bar at 32 years
old can be just a great party seven days
a week
give us some time ready some tongues
ladies out doing tonight what do you
think
kevin and i we love women and it is a
passion and we have a lot of them coming
through here don't act like you've never
done it
they're not just all young we got the
cougar clans coming through here we are
not one to discriminate we take customer
service to the next level
cheers boys and girls
you know as a california american male
we were taught during college that uh
it's good binge drinking is fun
[Music]
why is everybody empty i am the fun
captain
she tried roofing me you see that i am
kind of the party guy i want to make
everyone have fun
[Music]
right now they're just kind of
drunk idiots
if you're after a drunken lap dance
you've come to the right place if you
want a good night's sleep you best go
elsewhere i'm exhausted and i keep
hearing these loud
noises outside these people are drunk
and it's driving me crazy and i'm gonna
go complain
what can i do for you i have a room
upstairs sure it's really noisy the
saloon is always first and then the
hotel just seems like an afterthought
this registered national landmark has
been run ragged by the owners and is
hemorrhaging money if the guys continue
to party and not take things seriously
the hotel's just going to close down if
i don't do something fast this place
won't last another 150 days let alone
years i think gordon is going to say
[ __ ] this place that they're screwed
[Music]
i'm on my way to murphy's in northern
california now this place is in amongst
some of the most stunning vineyards
anywhere in the
world a beautiful town look how busy
this place is as well littered with
stunning little tasting rooms now anyone
lucky enough to be running a small hotel
here should be sold out every night
if they're not they must be doing
something seriously wrong
[Music]
wow this really is a story
murphy's hotel had been placed in the
national register of historic places
nice
wow
hello how are you i'm good how are you
doing so first name is kanitha kanitha
nice to meet you is it always that busy
out there
um we usually do get pretty busy on the
weekends incredible we have about 16
tasting rooms just within walking
distance of the hotel i love how
historic this place is but have you not
updated the furniture since 1850
bloody hell
my god it's like going to your grandma's
funeral my god
there definitely is a difference between
historic and then tacky and old what we
have is definitely tacky looks like
someone's died in those chairs
so you've been here for a long time
about a year and a half and what's wrong
with the place um well management the
owners
the hotel is owned by three guys they're
in their early 30s there's kevin joel
and brian and they really like to use
the hotels their playground
um partying drinking giving lap dances
to the bar patrons
so uh
there's lap dancing lap dances
while they're bartending
the owners that they continue partying
and giving lap dances in the bar and
acting how they've been the place is
just gonna keep going downhill
we put you in the presidential ulysses s
grant room
this is the actual bed that president
grant slept in except for the mattress
we did get rid of that what's the glass
box fort um this is our display room
display room yes so guests and customers
can come up and take a look
when were these last um replaced
terrific
oh [ __ ] i can't really tell you that uh
it sounds like i'm in a museum so my
guest or an example you're a guest
darling
what these people do
come on through everybody take a look
inside
this is
okay we're gonna be on display today
it's usual for the tourists to come
through sometimes and if a guest checks
in and they just for some reason forget
to close their door they're gonna have
people crowded around looking at them
they literally come over and they hello
hi
well that's embarrassing it's like a
goldfish bowl in here ladies thank god i
wasn't in my underpants
is that normal they just come and have a
look around um
yeah you know um we normally get
complaints and there's really no one
that handles that or takes care of it
but there's three owners yes a lot of
the time they're busy bartending or
drinking
or lap dancing exactly
unfortunately okay i'm gonna unpack can
this uh room be off the tour for a while
we'll see what we can do thank you
you're welcome
first impressions i mean it may be
steeped in history but it smells like
the room steeped in piss
we put you in the presidential ulysses s
grant room i've just arrived at murphy's
hotel near sacramento california it's
like i'm in a museum we're gonna be on
display today hello
thank god i wasn't in my underpants
time for a bite to eat i hope the food
here is less stale than my bedroom
ah murphy's historical employee of the
month
oh he looks so happy bunny oh hello how
are you how do you won
party at once
not a party for one uh good to see you
i'm brian is that the same
congratulations employee of the month
um did you get a bonus so you got a nice
stay yeah
i'm one of the only employees that never
made the cut yet i see you just put
yourself in and what are the owners
going to say about that i'm one of them
i'm brian stop it yes come on hey the
other owners out there shot on there
you're the owner and you made yourself
employee of the month yeah
are you the man with the g string the g
string receptors tell me did you do that
dancing oh no that would probably be
kevin i always say i don't know my
booty's a little too big to do this okay
i was gonna say i can't wait to see that
one
i would love to meet the other two the
chef on the lap dancer are they around
oh you only bring them out yeah all
right kevin and joel and i we're all
equal shareholders in this business but
it was my plan to buy the hotel hello
gavin kevin gordon good to see you thank
you now this is all right gordon joel
joel so you're the lap dancer
there's might have been some laptops oh
okay they're right i'm just just i'm
dying to find out i'm not a professional
maybe once in a while but okay fine
i'm a wild one when i start drinking i
get a little strip red action going on
or a little rowdy and can be the most
fun that any young adult could ever
dream of
so obviously the chef yes restaurant
manager
and the lab dancer bar manager bar
manager so who's in charge
all three of us
no such thing
so who runs the hotel who's in charge of
the
hotel hotel manager job doesn't really
entail
much with three owners normally there's
one that takes the reins and two other
silent none of you sound and look like
an owner
well gordon thinks we don't look like
owners but what what's the owner look
like we bought the hotel nine months ago
right and you guys go back a long way
just kind of met each other 15 years ago
and i'm confused whether it's the three
musketeers or three stooges
anyway i'm gonna have a quick bite to
eat it's been a long journey i'm excited
to taste the food thank you nice to meet
you thank you pleasure gordon's gonna
love our food joel works really hard at
everything he puts out everything that
comes out the window is a great product
i can't believe this hotel is owned by
three guys
uh with a pink dining room pink's new
black well it's like a girl's bedroom
ghastly gastly um any specials on today
we had a fresh alaskan halibut
with uh
now that i'm talking to you i've
completely forgot no we had we had the
halibut with a
well this is the first time i forget
specials don't worry why don't you check
with the chef all right i will you are
the question manager right yes and i was
a server too russian manager employee
the mum an owner yes all the above
employee of the month i'm going to take
that plaque back can't remember the
specials
hey joel i forgot the special just now
ryan just kind of forgot her specials i
have seen him do that before
the special's available tonight the
macadamian encrusted halibut right let's
try this cargo entrees lamb shank and
then what's the calamari door what does
dorm mean it's a dorae it's just a
calamari steak oh i'll go for that as
well okay thank you i'll keep all the
menu thank you very much you're welcome
once gordon has a bite of joel's food
put her in he's gonna put a smile on his
face guaranteed
[Music]
thank you
here we go sir
go in a red wine garlic sauce red wine
garlic
wow
geez absolutely rancid have a little
taste
i mean
nothing's hot
uh yeah strange taste you know that's
the first actually the first time in the
history that i've eaten the escargot
already and um i'm gonna say that i i
don't like it in any way no the escargot
tasted like a dirty funky disgusting
flip-flop if you uh sauteed a flip-flop
i think that would be a good
good way of describing it that was
[ __ ] disgusting
i do i want to run home and get some
mouthwash for sure but i don't know do
whatever you need to all right yeah
cause i stink
can worse water for you
please
do you have any um little samples of
like wine flights anything regional
we've talked about that but we have not
implemented it
so you've been talking about it for nine
months but you haven't actually done it
yet no one's even
bothered the sort of wine flight so
trying to get it together so so you've
had this place almost a year and you
haven't implemented something that this
town thrives on correct right
have you tasted there's a skull have you
escargot no really have you eaten i mean
you eat here right very often
and when was the last time you guys sat
down and had dinner in the restaurant
you never sat down with all three of us
together strange stranger i'm getting
slightly nervous that nothing actually
gets done here
anyway i'm living in hope we have some
more bread for sure
i got the lamb chicken coming right out
bro
oh my god
come on
holy crap what is that this is our lamb
shank that's a weird looking lamb shank
visually it looks like the biggest plate
of puke
i've never personally had lamb shank
ever been here i do not like lamb you're
the russian manager you don't like lamb
don't eat this i'm not yeah i'm the
restaurant manager but i'm not i'm not
the chef wow i think i would just call
that a dog's dinner what a mess
i do apologize again
i'm totally embarrassed that our food is
this quality i've always thought it was
better
hey joel yes the lamb shank he mentioned
that the vegetable gravy goo was a
little little too much oh i'm gonna run
this out okay
so fine dining frozen inedible
nasty excrement i mean i i'm amazed
what's this one this is the calamari
dore steak that's not garlic in there
again is it there is garlic in there
again
just how that dish is prepared
everything's just laced with garlic
please
be my guest
what is it trying to be a sponge
[Music]
i'm embarrassed i'm chewing on it going
i just want to spit this [ __ ] out right
now like this is terrible
so that's the first bite i've ever taken
of that you know this stuff's on the
menu right you're aware of it this is
your hotel yes yes i'm not being punked
here that you guys are the owners we are
the owners you almost haven't sent the
sons in to take the hit no no you
definitely are there this is us okay
how do these three stooges qualify to
run
an historic hotel like this
if they can't even get the food and wine
right how are they gonna improve the
hotel i feel like i'm being looked after
by college kids do they want me to come
out or you'd probably be good yeah come
on out
sorry weren't very impressed uh no i
mean far from impressed
have you ever actually stood back and
looked at that lam shank as a dish and
it's most horrendous the most drabby
disgusting looking [ __ ] lamb shank
have you given up no no no way we just
started we're not giving up yet you just
started yeah have you ever just
walked in from outside
checked in went up to the rooms and
you've never done that never have you
ever done that no i said have you ever
done that i have not oh my god
what have you improved on since you
bought it truthfully i make people laugh
and smile every day seriously what have
you changed weekends we serve breakfast
all day what have you changed menu-wise
manual um
um [ __ ] hell
i got one two three
three idiots that haven't changed
anything
you don't stay here you don't eat
together you don't criticize the food
[ __ ] reception
[ __ ] room ship food
and three clueless owners
owners
my [ __ ] ass i'm staying at murphy's
hotel in northern california
and after being put on display for
gawking tourists
and eating an atrocious lunch i think i
would just call that a dog's dinner what
a mess
i need to see the three nitwit owners in
action
word has got out that i'm in murfrees
and the hotel and restaurant are full of
people i feel sorry for all of them
joel is running the kitchen chicken's
burn
kevin is getting busy in the bar and
brian is overseeing the dining room
it should be gear nice guillotines
yeah isn't it guiller cheese
gria grier i
mean so guests trying to check in are
left to fend for themselves
[Music]
is uh everybody okay
uh yeah we're waiting we went up to the
front desk and there's nobody there so
trying to check in for
the uh
it's one of the owners that i guess i
just arrived to check in you get brian
urgently or kevin what about it about i
guess checking in oh yes check in i can
do that yeah would you please i'm sorry
excuse me you shouldn't have to come
looking for us in the park
[Music]
so that's what happens when guests come
in late they go to the bar looking for
yes that is uh how we do it you ever
done that checked in and then found the
reception closed and went into the bar
looking for key
no no no i've actually only stayed at
hotels probably only a matter of 20
times my whole entire life wow on your
hotel i know yeah so how come you guys
don't have anybody up here we got the
bartenders or servers like me sometimes
taking care of it
just sign the top there please
once guests get to the rooms they're in
for another unpleasant surprise
[Music]
let's wait for the drunkards to go home
before we open that up
[Applause]
[Music]
the owner's ignorance is evident in
everything i've seen so far i'm curious
to see what it's like in the parts i
haven't seen like the walk-in fridge
i thought that is
raw pork cooked chicken
sat next to each other [ __ ]
disgusting
i wish i'd seen this before i had my
lunch
yeah fine dining it's not look at that
[ __ ] it look at the mould going on there
certain [ __ ]
bloody hell there's more at the sides
too
oh jesus christ of look at the [ __ ]
mould on that this is absolutely
disgusting
so the walking how often is that fridge
cleaned out
twice a week yes
everything out yes yeah yes
come with me all of you all right
especially owners sounds good
sounds good ready [ __ ] you now
oh wow
oh wow
oh wow
okay moldy tortillas there should not be
[ __ ] any moldy [ __ ] food it's
[ __ ] horrible and when was this made
last saturday no i needed it
just smell that need to toss it i know
that
i'm this terrible you should be [ __ ]
ashamed okay
okay no it's not okay what is that it's
gonna be tot uh black mold what's this
supposed to be thai chili marinade thai
chili marinade but i don't know if it's
been used in a while the sauces was from
a chef that had been there like in 2006
or seven or something
this is exactly the same way as you run
this [ __ ] hotel
you don't give a [ __ ]
i give you [ __ ] i give a [ __ ] if this is
your dream of running a hotel then how
about manning up and look like [ __ ]
owners we are this is [ __ ]
unacceptable and it's not going to
happen anymore have you checked out
because you should do that with the
thing say to these two [ __ ] it he's not
checked out
he's in he don't talk i have not checked
out and i obviously i need to pay more
attention and do better at my job
how any of you can run a [ __ ]
business do you ever see three ceos
three [ __ ] general marriages no three
[ __ ] executive chefs ah
it's like dumbo dumber and donuts
since my arrival at murphy's hotel in
northern california you should be
[ __ ] ashamed i've been appalled by
the three clueless owners it's like
dumbo dumber and dumbest
are you guys really the [ __ ] owners
true story
[ __ ] off
[Music]
unbelievable i mean three young idiots
that are playing at running a hotel and
not one of them with a [ __ ] clue
i'm mad at joel i'm a [ __ ] owner i
don't [ __ ] want to clean i've been
here 12 hours it's unacceptable
i do want to prove gordon ramsay wrong
about me being a [ __ ] idiot [ __ ]
dumb and dumber [ __ ] scoundrel wanker
[ __ ] whatever british [ __ ]
terminology that [ __ ] wanker has to
say across from the [ __ ] different
guy but i do respect him
time to get a drink
you know i'm going to go play poker in
reno later tonight and i'm not going to
sleep
listen to that [ __ ] music
how on earth is anyone going to ever get
to sleep in this hotel jesus christ
that's crazy
ass is for everyone in this build right
here right
[Applause]
now annoying is this this doesn't make
sense
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
unreal
there's got to be a quite a room
somewhere
[Music]
[Applause]
it
surely
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] here we go
hey i i have a walk-in to clean i've
been here i want to go get that cleaning
because it's number one right now is
this uh
this is a joke
just a joke they're partying and i'm
upset and uh we're just i don't know
they're a party
they wanted to see it and uh i was upset
earlier and i'm upset i'm joel i'm not
upset at everything that's going on and
i want this is i'm just upset
how about thank you for two minutes
about your guests
i'm gonna go clean the walk-in i'm gonna
go clean the walk-in they just walk off
like that hey you know what i'm gonna go
clean the water because you know why why
acting like a [ __ ] jerk because i'm
i'm upset that was [ __ ] unacceptable
on there is unacceptable i'm [ __ ]
walking with a [ __ ] black male so why
don't you do something about it hey i
was i if i would it's not everyone in
this book
i'm going to clean the world they just
walk off
why acting like a [ __ ] jerk brian is
coming undone and he's drinking on the
job i'm done trying to get through to
him today i'm i'm upset that was [ __ ]
unacceptable in there
the [ __ ] walking
okay you're drunk
go home all right
i'm gonna go pick a walk-in now too
i'm gonna do it in a t-shirt jesus
christ i've been told the hotel offers
modern rooms further from the bar so
i've asked to be put in one so i can get
away from all this madness
[Music]
and they call these modern rooms it
looks like my grandma's house from the
1950s look at this wallpaper hideous
and what sort of hotel is this when you
can't get a good night's sleep
[Applause]
this was supposed to be quieter down
here
[Music]
what an awful night's sleep
[Music]
[Music]
this place is such a mess
from the awful decor to the dreadful
food to the drunken partying all night
long
i need to get the whole team together
and find out how it's gotten into this
state
morning guys good morning let's uh
get upstairs have a meeting probably
yeah with a team cool
[Music]
[Applause]
man that was a bad night's sleep the
noise above here was insane i came back
downstairs last night and brian's
ripping his shirt up
shouting screaming about hey shot's all
on me
is that normal
is that really how these managers
operate
when they're off duty they come behind
the bar turn up the jukebox when i've
already turned it down pour themselves
drinks their personal frat house
how does that make you feel your
employees are concerned that you're
drunk in the bar
when do i treat you all [ __ ] badly
what yeah when it comes to scheduling
how many days that you guys have asked
off for that you didn't get off there's
nothing asking
if you're gonna run a hotel it's not
about having a [ __ ] party it's about
levels of discipline well just so you
know it's not happening anymore but i'm
not gonna be as happy sometimes for you
guys
you are as good as your team they
represent you and based on what i've
seen i don't think you represent them
properly okay you go first and tell
these owners what they need to hear we
lose a lot of reservations when we don't
have somebody to answer the phone you
know when we leave the front desk we put
the phone in the bar after 8 pm we are
the front desk we are the bartenders i
saw that last night yeah they don't
answer the phone because they don't hear
it
we need online booking you know what
that takes away online bookings as a
front desk girl as you know we've talked
about getting rid of the front desk and
putting a computer there and we don't
have a person there self checking so how
do you feel about that so they complain
you threatened to fire them yep no
that's not what it is
yes it is you just totally attacked me
i'm afraid to express my feelings i'm
afraid i'm gonna get fired ready
nobody's threatened here with their job
nobody has you never threatened me by
being fired i have before were you drunk
yes you were drunk so
that's the message i'm trying to get
through to your fake skulls
you're threatening staff whilst
inebriated this is crazy people who
deserve to be fired are these three
standing here there's no structure
somebody needs to step up and run the
business and everybody else follow suit
you need one general manager that's the
issue you need to be a leader from the
top that's one person there can be 25
owners but there needs to be one general
manager if something doesn't change you
guys are going to lose this place
okay
which one of you is capable of stepping
up and running this business
i'm at murphy's hotel in northern
california you're the owner and you made
yourself the employer of the month yeah
the place is a mess because these three
owners behave like frat boys cheers boys
and girls
and none of them is a leader you checked
out so the staff don't know which way to
turn i'm afraid to express my feelings
so i'm afraid i'm gonna get fired
things have got to change
there needs to be one general manager
somebody needs to take charge
[Music]
i'm gonna take charge i'm gonna run the
business i'm our leader out of us three
it's gonna be me guaranteed if you're
gonna run the hotel you got it you run
the hotel yep 100
so kevin and joel are you willing to
give him the support and the autonomy to
actually run this place
yes
yes
brian it's your responsibility now to
general manage and absolutely toe the
line but there are three rules rule
number one stop drinking on the floor
rule number two you have to stop working
the floor yeah and rule number three
you have to [ __ ] grow some
fast
brian does know the most out of the
three of them so i really do think if he
could stop his party in ways he could
really do it trust me if you don't grow
up now you never will i got it it's a
hotel not a frat house i'm not gonna be
drinking and uh i'm gonna be owner thank
god for that
thank you
thank you
i'm going to change i'm going to be more
of an owner and not a friend
co-worker and they're going to see a
different brian
the future of this historic national
landmark is now in brian's hands and i
need to know that he cares enough to be
responsible you are young ambitious
slightly naive you're going at it in
totally the wrong way you're on the
verge of losing this business
hopefully not and how would you feel if
you lost the business it would be
horrible it would be horrible because
that's already three years of uh 60 hour
weeks
it's horrible
i'm here to help but i want you to
understand the mess you're in it's not
good all right
do you understand i do
deep down inside there's no two ways
about it you're a fun guy you've got a
lot to offer yeah
but just stop being irresponsible
and just
man up yeah for sure you can do it okay
i want to make this work
from today on it's gonna be a change
business is different all right okay
okay
i couldn't see that smell back in your
face
thank you i'll see you later from this
day forward i'm a change man
and the business is going to reflect all
those changes
with brian ready to take charge as
general manager my design team has
worked all night to modernize murphy's
hotel and now it's time to reveal the
new look hotel to brian and his team
brian how are you sir gordon good how
are you doing you're very smart you guys
you doing i'm good yeah good to see you
mark ladies how are we yeah doing really
good good right
welcome everyone the new and improved
murphy's historic hotel are you ready
ready yeah yeah all right let's go do
this
welcome to your new lobby all right
awesome no it is awesome exactly how it
should be
yeah when i first walked in i was
disappointed it was just like a big
anti-climax now you have a nice warm ah
modern feel the minute you walk in but
your guests will arrive
and feel welcomed yeah
take a seat
is it beautiful yes amazing amazing
brian what'd you think beautiful
absolutely beautiful welcoming
contrast perfect what gordon has done
with the lobby is beautiful now that
blue it's so warm it's so welcoming it's
awesome this is a historic hotel your
ex-president stayed here yes that
doesn't happen that often in hotels
thank you happy birthday
to you guys thank you thank you hold on
thank you there's more
from six o'clock this morning you're now
live with online
bookings don't go anywhere near the bar
you know what time they're coming and
you are now
in the 21st century yeah are you ready
to see the presidential suite yeah yeah
all right president come see my room
let's go
i think you'll love it let's go jump in
oh my gosh that was awesome oh my
goodness
this one's been freshened up this one's
been spruced up you need that vibrance
the minute you walk into a room you want
to feel wow i'm stepping into history
but i also want some comfort this is fit
for a president our president now could
stay here
obama would be okay to stay here now
it still feels historic but it's a
bedroom not a museum exactly so you know
make sure that when your guests are
checked in their bedrooms are off the
tour did you put a new robes is there
something on here to make it all be
lined and cushioned
for me the
big problem wasn't the linens it was the
noise we've come up with a solution to
narrow that down last call midnight well
stick to those times of your bar closing
because the damage you can do to your
reputation is devastating yep
we're gonna follow through and make sure
that our customers in hotel are as happy
as our customers in the bar and our
customers in the restaurant right you
already see the rooms outside that you
told me were modern okay all right
let me show you what modern is you ready
you can see why i got upset the owner's
done nothing in nine months
so we've done all this in [ __ ] 24
hours
i'm blown away i can't believe the the
creativity that's been put into this
place in the last few days joe what do
you think very uh last words inspired
you know very inspiring you know listen
you should never ever ever be afraid of
change you've got to keep on going oh
yeah
brian what do you think what's going
through your mind i've never heard you
say quiet breathtaking though i don't
even know what to say because it's
beautiful is it so beautiful this is
perfect with this kick in the ass we're
going to go forward full throttle and
make changes that no one's ever seen
before you ready to see the dining room
yes yes this one i love the dining room
where do you start buddy
look at the colors come in you got it
beautiful where's the pink oh my god
yeah gone are those horrendous pink
walls a stunning beautiful color on the
walls that just pop and there's one more
thing
this bit you're gonna love
it's a surprise that's gonna completely
change your business you ready for this
[Applause]
[Music]
i've just revealed the stunning new
improvements to the historic murphys
hotel
our president now could stay here and
now there's one more addition that will
ensure this hotel thrives in the future
you are in the heart of some of the most
sought-after wineries anywhere in the
world and is a massive market that you
have been missing out on and here's why
every famous winery has a lovely tasting
room on this main street at five o'clock
they close here you're not gonna pick up
that business this is a menu designed to
pair with great local wines oh wow look
at that okay oh my goodness this is
incredible oh my gosh start off with
that lovely cheese plate the chicken
liver cassini paired with a stunning
chilled rose and then this wonderful
local
local ricotta dip you now have a perfect
menu when those tasting rooms close at
five o'clock you pick it up and you
continue it and where they're gonna stay
the night yeah
that's right after dinner i want you to
dig in um and sample the wine tasting
menu is awesome the overall experience
to any guest that walks through our door
now i believe is gonna be better than
ever i like the pairing of the
bruschetta and the
the wine that it goes with it's a very
nice fresh dish there's no going back no
they're only going up now yeah
oh that's nice
oh this is so phenomenal this is gonna
put us on the map
off the charts reservations off the hook
thank you chef thank you thank you as
well as a wine pairing menu i've changed
the entire menu in the dining room let
me show you one of my favorite dishes
i'm very excited about the new menus i
know where i'm eating every night
oh my god fresh baked lemon meringue pie
oh my goodness look at that thing and
the
real inspiration behind this
was brian's hair
[Applause]
and where's mark simpson
this new menu is going to touch a
business a clientele that we've never
had at the murphy's hotel and i know
personally i can't wait to eat there
more often
with warm and fresh rooms and the new
wine tasting menu my only concern is
whether brian can stay focused on the
guest experience
listen every night from now on in in
this hotel is a big night let me tell
you
and it's not just about the bar but the
restaurant and the rooms push those
tasting menus
in that bar gm are you ready we're ready
um if there's one thing you do not need
as a general manager as an apron get
that off all right
good luck guys thank you thank you are
you ready all right we're ready yes
[Applause]
hello how are you doing good how are you
with extended front desk operating hours
guests can easily check in and feel
welcome in the new lobby
wow looks nice i'll better be a
comfortable sleeper i know it's going to
be fun
and they're enjoying the renovated and
peaceful rooms i wish this is my bedroom
this is the new sim harlow and the wine
tasting menu is a hit
that fillet looks lovely guys they're
loving the food keep it going yes
good luck
when i first arrived you saw three young
guys sort of playing running a bar and
completely forgetting that they were
actually in charge of a hotel
but brian stepped up and has taken that
general manager role which is great news
i'm hoping now that they get that party
mode out of their mind and focus on the
potential of what this business can
bring them
uh great job um you performed like
owners tonight you sound like owners and
this place you know is rocking the
atmosphere in the bar is controlled the
dining room's having fun the patio is
full the wine tasting menu is flying out
keep it the good work okay gordon he
really has opened my eyes and showed me
that we need to take more of a
leadership role as an owner i'm taking
him out of the employee the month i know
choose one together yes on a monthly
basis have your input yeah throw it into
the pot i believe gordon has saved his
place by putting wind in our sails again
we truly did need a kick in the ass
because we were playing around a little
too much general manager remember
actions speak louder and worse your next
day you'll hear great things i guarantee
gordon is amazing he's a magician and i
think that he came through and he
transformed the hotel into this
wonderful masterpiece and i'm so
thankful that he came through and helped
us what a gorgeous place
damn i never did get to see kevin lap
dance
since my visit to the historic murphys
hotel the owners have finally become
owners joel is keeping the kitchen and
the walking extra clean and he has new
pride in his work i got a well done
going right there you can go peek at the
upstairs bathrooms
ones down the hall showers both
restrooms upstairs you stay there i'm
good right here
brian is stepping up as general manager
focusing his efforts on the hotel brian
is definitely capable of being the
general manager gordon has completely
changed everything
gordon brought the historic hotel back
to life
[Music]